cook there drew heavily on history he
was quite you know trying to be very
inspirational here motivating the
students how did he do Tim yeah well the
student says seemed to be pretty excited
this is really the Tim Cook who has
emerged in the last eight months or so
being more socially active more of a
voice for a quality and against heat
injustice and that in that sort of thing
coming out in Business Week magazine
late last year proud didn't say that he
was gay and since then we've seen him be
more active such as taking a stand
against an Indiana law that was passed
earlier this year that critics said was
against homosexuality and it's it's a
it's a new more open Apple it is a new
more open Apple as you say a new tim
cook as well so you know he's always
going to be a comparative course Tim to
his predecessor Steve Jobs and I can't
tell you how many CEOs business leaders
continually refer to that Stanford
speech back in 2005 that Jobs made and I
want to play for our viewers part of
that inspirational speech your time is
limited so don't waste it living someone
else's life don't be trapped by Dogma
which is living with the results of
other people's thinking don't let the
noise of others opinions drown out your
own inner voice and most important have
the courage to follow your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you truly want to become everything else
is secondary so is that the speech by
which tim cook will always be measured
by well i think jim cook is oftentimes
only measured by his predecessor and
that's kind of the curse of being Tim
Cook but if you look at yesterday's
speech there was some echoes of that of
Steve Jobs a belief that you can change
the world and that's what Tim was really
saying because these students was that
the the old idea that you have to choose
a profession / doing good are no longer
the case and he was urging at the urging
these new grads to go out and find jobs
that would allow them to also do well
and did he say anything
that was worthy of you writing about in
terms of apple products well he did
suggest that if students didn't have
apple iphones with them that they passed
their competitors items to the aisle and
he could recycle that for them but other
than that i know he we want interesting
side note he was you talked about how
apple products have really helped people
of the world from the blind to people
who are in isolation we have more access
to technology and also pointed out that
these iphones now have cameras in them
and their inputs cameras in people's
pockets so then whenever they see
injustice they can take pictures of it
and just him you know we can't ignore
the other news around Tim Cook which is
her icon in just the last couple of
hours making some comments to Tim Cook
writing a letter to him saying you
should buy back more shares I see a
price target of two hundred forty
dollars but he also said he sees a
skinny bundle for Apple TV and an apple
car what do you make of that yeah that's
that's the dream that Apple has more
hits in the future